suited and booted these factory workers
are practicing social distancing and
ensuring health and safety standards are
maintained they're making thousands of
masks a day by hand it can push the ear
and it cannot receive the word like many
other countries around the world there's
a shortage of gear to protect Afghans
against kovat 19 you know Afghanistan is
a poor country we doesn't have enough
money to spend for protecting our people
I myself tried to help Afghanistan
because in the international market a PP
kid courses around the $60 but in here
just in $5 with the same standard the
factory in the capital Kabul is also
providing employment opportunities I was
jobless before this and was doing
nothing in lockdown at home but I'm
lucky that I have this job now serving
my people the government says corona
virus has infected close to 3,000 people
but the true total is feared to be much
higher there are not enough testing kits
and it's difficult to track case numbers
especially in rural areas nearly a third
of 500 people tested for kovat 19 out of
a population of 5 million in the capital
Kabul were positive in a bid to contain
the virus the nationwide lockdown has
been extended until May 24 but has
widely been ignored by the public so
this is not a complete lockdown why
hasn't the government insured and
implemented a complete lockdown two
factors primarily one is massive
unemployment in poverty I mean a hungry
man is an angry man you cannot keep him
and push him to be at home all the time
up to a quarter of a million poor
families living in Kabul started
receiving 10 pieces of bread a day in
the first phase of the government
handout program the charity saved the
children warns millions of Afghan
children are at risk of going hungry
food is also being distributed by
community volunteers going door to door
to raise safety awareness during the
pandemic poor people are contacting us
for help but unfortunately we cannot
fine enough help we prioritize the
poorest of the poor for example the
widows who have no one to take care of
them decades of war in Afghanistan has
damaged the health system hospitals rely
on aid from the World Health
Organization and countries such as China
and Turkey
despite the foreign help Afghanistan
remains poorly prepared for a major
outbreak Zara here at al-jazeera